hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new and inspiring
software engineers and today is going to
be much more relaxed more of a
conversation i'm going to share with you
my experience with a six hour interview
day a super day they call it and
i thought that this was you know just
right timing and everything because you
know what today is
super bowl day and i'm talking about my
own super day so i was like you know
what let's
chill let's just like have some fun
today and let me just share a story with
you all
so let's get to it so this happened
this last fall it was the end of october
of 2020 i had just finished my
coding boot camp at flatiron school
finished that
the first week of october and i had been
interviewing with this company that is
my dream company
dream dream company and i assure you
all of you know it or if you don't know
it you interact with it without
knowing it and so one day i see
an email pop-up saying that i got to the
third and final round of interviews
and so i was just you know so ecstatic
so excited
until you know i read i read a little
bit more down i was scrolling scrolling
up and
i saw the time commitment
it said 11 a.m to 5
p.m eastern time
[Music]
so you know you can imagine my own
you know shock and you know
stress levels when i saw that
this is actually something i've been
through in the past this is called
a super day a super day interview where
you have you know
anywhere from four to eight hours of
interviewing i've been through about
three
other ones in the past back when i was a
college student
i remember going on location to a
company to interview
from literally nine a.m to six pm
and i ended up not getting the job but
you know i'm not bitter
but yes this is something some companies
do
this is to allow for different
departments to you know get
to learn about the candidate um get you
at the candidate
different things and for everyone at the
end of the day to come together
and see what they thought about this
person
and decide if they should give them an
offer so it's not something i
you know was estranged to
or you know didn't know about but still
y'all y'all
sorry i'm moving my foot it's falling
asleep y'all six hours
is a long time so the day before
the super day i was
um and other candidates were given a
hackerrank
problem to do hackerrank if you don't
know is
basically a portal or resource
that one people can use to
brush up their coding skills and you
know better their algorithm
skill sets and things like that learning
you know coding problems
but it's also something companies use to
basically
filter out candidate pools by sending
them
coding problems and so hacker extends
your problem they say
you need to solve this between this time
and this time and you have x amount of
time
to solve it and everything is
administered typically through the
company like they set
the expiry date they set the time limit
and everything
hacker rank more just administers it
and so we get sent a hackering for the
day before
our um super day and
y'all so this hackering
i ran out of time before i could even
finish it i was given about two hours
and i got about halfway before i was
like yo
i i'm just going into this loop of just
not knowing how to continue on and
while also producing the best quality
code that's the thing you want to
produce
the best quality code during these
hackings not just
solve the problem but it's also hard
because you have this
when you're on hacker rank there's this
like clock in front of you
that's just ticking down by the second
and it's just this big red reminder
of basically your hopes and dreams
slipping away
like like there's no like that's how it
feels
and so my time ran out and i didn't
finish it but i was like you know what
it ain't much but it's honest to work so
sent that over and was mentally
preparing for
my next day of interviews my
super day so now is
the day it's game day like we out here
coin toss flip everything so it's game
day
and my first interview was a technical
interview
which i was supposed to go over the
solution
um i produced this previous day through
the hacker and
walk through it with them and they would
give me a question
um as well and i would answer it on the
spot
i won i was so nervous because that
morning
so that morning before the interview
even started
i get an email and the email is like oh
hackering
score and everything i'm like perfect
i see this email y'all i got
a zero out of 75. that was my score that
hackard gave me a zero out of 75.
now i remind you i got about halfway
through the problem but it looks like
these people didn't care
it looks like hackering did not care you
know you didn't solve the problem so
it's a zero
so that was you know when i thought my
heart dropped especially because like i
was over here like
with you know baking my eyes and like
all that
my hair up like with my beauty blender
preparing for this interview
and then i see this email and i'm just
like i might as well not even show up
i might as well not even go like a zero
zero out of 75
and so i was very yeah very very scared
but um
funny enough so this this let this serve
as
a lesson to you all funny enough i get
to the technical portion
of the super day and they actually um
my interviewers actually say that they
were impressed by how far i
got so keep this in mind y'all
sometimes the problems you get are not
meant to be solved
they are problems that the company is
expecting you not
to solve and really what they might be
testing is your ability to
go about problem solving when you're you
know
in high pressure situations your ability
to
think about uh ways to solve it even
though you don't know how but think
about
what approaches you could take um and
all of that sometimes it's not actually
meant to be solved so next time you're
struggling during a coding interview
just have that attitude like you know
what they're not expecting me to solve
this
so let me make sure i show them anyway
what type of engineer i am and the way
i go about my problem solving
you know process and things like that
next
was a portion where we were put into
teams
and we had to basically produce like a
case
solution um to a problem we got
from the interviewers and so if you've
ever done like a case study
or if you've ever done like business
challenge problems it was like this
where
they give you a problem and you conduct
a whole full solution procedural
financials um and put in a presentation
and then you at the end of the day you
would end up presenting it
um in front of the like 50 60
different members of the teams
so this one this part was okay um
i remember like making sure i like
stayed
active and you know stay active but not
you know trumping other people's ideas
because that's not good that's not
what a leader is you don't trump
people's ideas but staying
active and being able to facilitate
conversation
and discussion so that was like really
like what i was trying to do there so
that was okay
then i go to my behavioral and so i get
to my behavioral and for the most part
it was good
so for me behavioral interviews for me
is like
what carries the team um because
i know i do get frenzied with technical
questions
and things like that um i know i get
like very panicky
that i can't even think but behavioral i
just like to show who i
am as a person i like to share what i've
done in the past and share what i'm
looking to do in this company and so i
like behavioral in that way and
behavioral has liked me in that way
however
so this this entire video is going to be
like
however like that's gonna be this entire
conversation
however with this behavioral interview i
kept like
i don't know i think it was because i
just wanted this company so bad
i would kind of like say something then
like get into this like
hole of like spiraling and just talking
and like
out i could hear myself talk and then
like out of me would kind of like
move away and be like yo like
stop talking like like end of the
question and i
and i would just like try to now wrap it
up because i see this out of me saying
yo what are you doing like
stop it and everything and so
like just like yeah talking and just
like trying to just trying to show these
people who i am
so after that behavioral
then we're supposed to go back into our
teams for the case
analysis go have another like maybe hour
to go through there before we present
this is where all hell broke loose y'all
like
all hell i
lose my internet so this is something
you know i
you know forget um when listening to
stories
where you know in a parallelogram and a
panda bear all that and so everything
was virtual i didn't you know get flown
out to the
offices or you know to the company for
these interviews
everyone was virtual so i was in my
basement
[Music]
yeah and i'm just like what happened
to my internet like nothing is working
nothing is working i had so
flashback to my other three interviews
with different companies
i have a two-year-old baby brother y'all
he is a very adorable like
light of my life except for the times
where he
comes into my interviews and i
if my parents are watching this like you
know
you know how i feel about this i have
because at the time
um i was living at home i no longer live
my home by the time i was living at home
and so i would tell them like yo like
i'm going to be an interview
in an interview from this time to this
time make sure the baby's away
and like please be quiet like because
you could hear footsteps like crazy you
could hear if people were
talking if people were if the baby was
crying you could hear it and you could
hear it
through a computer as well and i was
like please like be quiet and like
just let me have these 30 minutes these
this one hour
three times my baby brother has come
into my interviews
and i'm like yo like where were you
i told you like this is my job i'm
trying to get a job
and you can't watch this two-year-old
for 30 minutes like please
please watch him and so
um for this interview because they knew
you know how much i wanted this
they decided to just leave the house
they were like you know what we're not
even going to be around because
every time we're around something goes
wrong so they all left
they all left except for my dad my dad
had um i believed worked the night
before and so
he just you know he needed his rest and
so he was
um in their room sleeping so but
everyone else is away
so the internet goes out and i'm like
oh my god like i need so first thing i
do is i text the recruiter and i'm like
yo i'm so sorry like my internet's not
working i'm gonna like i'm gonna call
the provider and see what's going on
i run upstairs to my dad and i'm like
the internet is out like
like what what's going on and so he
calls the provider
and they're like this says your internet
is fine and everything and so then
they try to like reboot everything and
i'm i keep just texting my recruiter
like i'm so sorry i'm supposed to be
meeting with my team
to practice our presentation um which is
like one of the like most important
parts
of that interview and everything like
i'm just like please like i beg of you
like please
get get back and get this internet back
and everything
an hour goes by and now i have like
i was like 10 minutes before not even 10
minutes y'all
like an hour goes by and so i missed the
slot for me
to meet with my team on our presentation
and now teams are actively presenting
to um the boards and like the
workers of this company and everything
and so after an hour of like just cons
like going back and forth in all of this
i get my bag i get my computer and i
drive
i get out the door and i drive like a
mad woman to my nearest
starbucks luckily i live like
two and a half minutes from a starbucks
so it really took like
no time at all especially with the way i
was driving up in these streets
so i drove drove drove and
set my computer down put up the wife
because i knew starbucks had free wi-fi
and so put up you know my laptop to get
free wi-fi and everything
and i show up um
show up but you know i get to the
video stream or whatever the virtual
meeting
of you know this last section of the
interview which was the presentation
and it was so embarrassing because
now i got there literally just in time
for us to present and it sounds like i'm
saying like oh this time but really it
was like 30 minutes no
i was just in time i get there i text
my recruiter i'm like i'm here i'm here
and everything and
um you know now we're supposed to be
presenting
it was so embarrassing because i get
there
and my team is like hey nya um
you are doing slides at five and six
in front of everybody like in front of
like the and i'm not blaming my team but
i'm saying more of a thing of like
now like how like everyone knows
my how i'm unprepared for this
and so i'm in front of 50 60 people
and i have no idea what slide five and
six
are so now i have to pull up the slides
um the google's luckily it was google
slides like no one had to send me
anything so
the automatic you know loading and all
allowed me to see the
most recent version of the presentation
look up
slides five and six and i like you know
i'm
reading it over and i'm just trying to
like see how to present it in a way that
shows i'm not just
reading off of it and i'm actually you
know
i actually have some cells up in here
too and you know show that i would be a
great person for this company
and so you know now it's my turn for the
slides and
i talk and i try to add in some
background information just from what i
know of the company
and then you know i breathe a little bit
like okay like my part is done
and um yes then we're done presenting
and
they asked a question um just like you
know those like panel questions
you know so they ask a question and i
made
sure you can best believe i made sure to
answer that question
and so i made your chance of the
question um talking about like more like
inclusivity and all of this
and they're like thank you like that was
great and so
now i'm in my car waiting for the phone
call as to
if i would get the job or not the reason
i was waiting in my car
is because i had an offer
expiring 30 minutes after the
end of this super day
and i had said this to the recruiter
that i have an
offer expiring just 30 minutes after
please tell me as soon as possible if i
get this job
because if i don't then i'll i'll take
this other one but
i want you um so i'm
just i couldn't even bring myself to
start driving like i sit in my car
and i call a few friends and i'm just
crying
just saying like how bad this day was
like everything like just bad
bad bad and how just frenzied i was from
everything from the technical interview
me you know showing me starting out with
the xerox 75
to then lights literally going out
you know and me having no way of
you know being a part of this interview
because now
i don't have internet don't have you
know all of this
and having to drive to starbucks where
everyone sees i'm at a starbucks
everyone sees i'm at this
public location with literally i
remember the symbol with bruno mars
playing in the background when i'm
trying to give my portion of the
presentation
like it was just like i was just crying
and so then um
i get a call from my recruiter and he's
like hey
yeah um the thing about my recruiter so
i have loved interacting um
with this recruiter he is someone who
obviously cares about the applicants and
the
you know contenders is that i feel like
i'm talking about like hunger games when
i say the word contenders
but about the future you know employees
of this company the future engineers
and so he is someone that like i also
just didn't want to disappoint you know
what i mean because like
now we have been talking for like a
month now from my first interview to now
um and like i just now didn't want to
let him down
and so i remember listening to him um
and like
he had like a very monotone like voice
and so i was just like
it's over it's over it's over like you
should just text me the rest like
you don't need to tell me like how you
chose someone else like um
but he's like yeah so you know we loved
you
and you know we'd love for you to work
with us and this is the salary
and we'll send you more information
later
and i'm like
okay i'll talk to you later goodbye
and i was just shaking i remember
screaming have you guys seen that video
if you haven't seen this video please
look it up
um it's this woman who got out of um an
interview
and um like got on a call like on the
phone
the person said she got the job or
something or she walked out of the
building
having gotten the job and she stops in
the parking lot and it's just like
dancing look it up look up like maybe
like woman who gets a job
dancing in parking lot it is the
funniest video that was
me out and it's funny because like this
happened like a week within each other
so
i remember that i remembered that video
in that moment but i was just like
like in my car and i remember just like
yeah like if
someone's looking at me in my car just
like going wild like i was just
so happy and i have not lost that
feeling
since then just so happy looking back
i do see how like being hard on myself
negatively
um impacted the experience because like
they um very much put weight on like
trying to
make this as enjoyable as possible for
people
it is you know six hours but it's six
hours for a reason they're trying to
get you to know more about the company
and for
the different departments and different
department heads and co-workers to know
about more about you in the most fun way
possible and so i
wish like knowing what i know now about
like what they truly wanted
to see out of me which was you know
potential for growth in a person who
they would just like to work with i
would have you know been
much less hard on myself and that much
less like in my head
um but no i am so so grateful
for that experience for this company
like i am so excited to work for them
and i'm so
grateful for my recruiter if my crew is
watching this like i'm so grateful for
you
um and i look forward to speaking with
you soon i still you know i hope you're
doing well i do think about
um yeah the next time we get to talk and
interact because like
speaking with you know the different
members of this company
and you know the recruiters and the
managers
it was just like it's looks like such a
family and such an amazing community
and so i'm very very grateful to be
a part of that and so yeah that is my
six hour interview story um my
super day on the day of the super bowl
story um so no i hope you all enjoyed
this like more relaxed conversation
and yeah subscribe if you'd like to you
know just
hang out some more you know be a part of
this community
and i'll see y'all soon bye